the new Pet Sematary has fans debating
the change as it made to the original
story but what I've also discovered is
that there are some radically different
endings of the remake that were almost
used in the final film yippee-ki-yay
movie lovers I'm John and in this video
I'm revealing the three incredible
endings you never got to see in the new
Pet Sematary including the happy endings
Stephen King recommended Plus keep
watching for more deleted scenes cut
from the final film spoilers ahead for
the movie so take care if you haven't
seen it yet the filmmakers of the new
Pet Sematary had three different endings
planned for the movie which they
described as dark darker and darkest now
the ending we actually got for the film
was pretty bleak with not just Ellie and
Rachel dying but Lewis also killed on
top of that in the movies final scene we
see the resurrected Lewis Ellie and
Rachel approaching the family sole
survivor gage is in a car looking out
the window at his undead family when we
hear the horrifying sound of the doors
unlocking the opening scene of the movie
showed us an opened car door with bloody
hand stains heavily indicating that poor
gage surely didn't survive this chilling
everyone dies twist on the original
story was the darkest version on the
table and if you found it too horrifying
for your liking you might have preferred
the much lighter ending that Stephen
King suggested the horror legend saw an
early cut once the filmmakers began
their reshoots and based on that he
recommended an ending where gages
walking up the middle of the road we see
dawn and we hear a truck coming and
think oh my god he's gonna get greased
in the road that's how this is gonna end
then at the last second this woman pulls
him out of the road and rescues him and
says words your mummy and daddy both
kings original story and the 1989 movie
had gage rather than early killed by a
truck in the road earlier in the story
so this alternate ending would have been
a hat tip to that with the twist being
that this time the little toddler is
saved King would have ended the movie
right there leaving the ultimate fate of
the woman engaged unknown as she goes
off his search of gages parents speaking
to ewk suggested he's a sucker for a
happy ending and it's interesting that
the finale he suggested for the remake
would have been drastically different to
how he ended his own book the second
alternate ending was actually filmed and
while it's still dark it's just a touch
lighter than what we saw in the
final movie in an interview with
Collider producer Lorenzo di Bona
Ventura describes what it entails
there's a version where mum and daughter
are both back from the dead and there's
a shot of Lewis with gage in his lap
both of them are normal and then mum
walks in she's clearly out there in
another world and daughter comes in and
daughter says hi mummy I love you and
then the cameras on them like a family
portrait and then it just pulls back and
the little kids crying and Louis just
looks like he's been run over by a bus
so in this version we still have an
undead Ellie and Rachel at the end and
although it seems unlikely that Lewis
engaged could survive the onslaught of
these two reanimated family members the
way it ends does leave open the
slightest possibility this alternate
ending is more of a direct play on the
original 1989 movies ending where Lewis
was waiting in the kitchen for the
resurrected corpse of Rachel to return
to him in that movie it showed Rachel
grabbing a knife and ended on Lewis's
screams which is why I think the second
alternate ending for the new film very
likely implies that Lewis engage will
both die a 2017 draft of the screenplay
also reveals yet another interesting
finale that could have been in this
ending it's Rachel who discovers Judds
dead body and then goes to look for
Ellie in the woods she finds her undead
daughter in the pet cemetery and armed
with drugs guns she tries to shoot Ellie
but mrs. Ellie attacks her mother with
the scalpel and during the fight
Rachel drops her revolver Ellie grabs
the gun aims it at her mother and with
pitch black eyes and a wicked smile on
her face she says love you mummy then
pulls the trigger but just at that
moment
Lewis arrives and in the aftermath we
discover he's the one who's been shot
Lewis dies leaving Rachel's stricken
with grief the undead Ellie then walks
over to her mother and goes to kill her
but notices something about her mother's
pain and instead whispers something to
her the scene then cuts to gauge asleep
in the car and suddenly Ally's there
smiling at him then Rachel walks over
unlocked the car door and takes gage
over to the front porch with her where
she sits down the camera pans out to
Ellie dancing in the yard and a shadow
appears in front of her Elle
lux up surprise and exclaims daddy at
which point the screen cuts to black so
as you can see this ending like the
others is pretty crazy and twisted it's
more open in terms of whether Rachel
engaged could survive but of course
they'd need to defeat the resurrected
Lewis and Ellie now if you watch the
trailers for the movie you'll probably
have noticed quite a few scenes missing
from the final film for example several
Zelda scenes didn't make it in including
this one of Zelda creeping up behind
Rachel and grabbing her other Zelda
scenes that were cut involved Rachel
experiencing more visions of her sister
when she visits her childhood home in
Boston in an interview with slash film
the directors described a deleted scene
where Rachel goes to her sister's
bedroom to confront her fear of her dead
sister in a moment similar to one in the
1989 movie the reason for this cut was
that the directors wanted to focus the
Zelda scenes on the house the family
moved to in Ludlow as by only having
visions of Zelda appear to Rachel and
the family's new house it emphasizes the
power the wendi-go has on the area near
the cursed burial ground the filmmakers
also said they didn't want the Zelda
storyline to overwhelm the film but
they've promised that will see these
extra scenes on the home entertainment
release interestingly enough though
Zelda wasn't actually in the original
script for the remake but when directors
Kevin Kolsch and Dennis wittmeyer came
on board they insisted on including
Zelda's story as it was vital to give
Rachel a more substantial role there's
another terrifying snippet in the
trailers that didn't make it in which
looks like a flashback to when Judds
wife Norma was alive this scene could
have been really interesting as it could
have helped explain why Ellie tells Jurg
that she's seen his dead wife Norma
burning in hell for what he did to her
in King's original novel the possessed
gage tortured about Norma cheating on
him with all his friends and in the book
Jude also has a brief history of having
visited prostitutes
Kolsch has said that the deleted scene
shows more of Joe's backstory and his
relationship with the burial ground
which leads me to think that when Norma
died Judge resurrected her but as with
everyone who comes back Norma wasn't
right you can see her here rocking back
and forth in a chair while an iron has
been left on in the background jed
probably had to kill the undead Norma
and now the wendi-go is using ellie to
come back as his wife to punish him
there are also some intriguing trailer
scenes of children in
masks that never made it into the final
movie in the film we only see the kids
as they parade down to the pet cemetery
but in the trailer there's also these
additional scenes of the children going
beyond the barrier all the way to the
cursed burial ground where they seem to
be burying a dead animal the directors
have revealed that these scenes were
only filmed for marketing the movie in
their interview with slash film they
explained that on studio films they send
marketing departments down and they
actually have their own camera unit and
they take your actors and go and shoot
things that are just specifically for
trailers and marketing spots in fact the
directors only saw those scenes for the
first time when they saw the trailer
they were slightly concerned that these
fake scenes so to speak might confuse
the audience but in the end they don't
think they did now what do you think
about any of these deleted scenes and
would you prefer any of the alternate
endings tap the screen to vote in the
poll and leave your thoughts in the
comments below and if you enjoyed this
subscribe and hit the bell to get all my
new videos next tap left for a full
breakdown of Pet Sematary including
Easter eggs so when do you go ant sequel
possibilities or tap right for my horror
movie deleted scenes playlist thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers